rar
ずゲー amazon でヅラのものを買いました今回あれだ突っつくいた邪魔だな
はいこんなでかいやつなんですけれども何切り出した
飛び出したそうあって使ったよねソファー僕うちにもねそこ上がるんだけどドンキで
買ったからすごいちょっと安いっぽいやつね
襲ってたさ
あんまりあんまりよくないんではなく享年
あのちょっとネットではないのです
スーパーソファーをちょっと買ってきましたではさっそく開けていきましょうばいばー
い
床に傷つくっよっ
を駆使
何はっはっは
ちゃんねるよしきたきたきたきたあないっていう
で大丈夫よしこちらでございます俺触ら注文してさあもう2週間くらい経つからさ
どんなんね売れてるんだよいやいやこれはやばいこれこれ本当欲しかったんだよ
me
こちらですああ
はいこちらがは人をダメにするソファでございます
まぁパッと見ただなく6番道具ですけどね相手がいいですね苦労は同部じゃなくて上段
にするぞ
なんかネットで見たことがあるんだよ本当に彼の6時でしかな
なんかそこら辺でこう本当に動きだけだけなるぐらいのソファンっているらしくて
もうねこれはね欲しいと思って買いましたよ8位
8いやはやいやはやソッコああ
吸い込まれる凄い凄いおおおおすごいつい壊れるめっちゃね沈むんですよ
これだなのか一緒に見えるけどさ神たーーーーもそうカードからねこれはこういう感じ
ですね
中でもうねーなんか何でもよくなってくんだよこれ
辛いこととかさって言われちゃうわけ足とかおいてもめっちゃ沈むんですよこうやって
おっっ
おいそして子供は座ってこう勉強とか
阿蘇ほんとが分けているし行わねぇ施工やってマジ欲しかった巧妙なステマになった
から
須磨じゃないんでね誰かで紹介しようと言われてるわけじゃないんだよなんだ使い道が
ないかな
永田台長いとこから落ちても大丈夫だぞ
こんなゲスカフェなら全然余裕だと思う
新座市
はぁ
よしチっつーまーす
いやまぁこれ自体は痛くなかった全然痛くなる怪談
緊急時にもこう助けてくれるっていうねとても優れボロドウダメにするソファなんで
ぜひね
その時の行ってみようじゃあ